this year's nominees for Best Adapted
Screenplay have brought their source
material brilliantly to life in a way
that adds movie magic to these
compelling tales here are the nominees
for Best Adapted Screenplay arrival
communicate by Eric hydrant sentence
screenplay by August Wilson based on his
play Sidney figures screenplay by Alison
Schroeder and Fyodor mouses based on
results by Margo leisurely lime-green
play by Lee Davis adapted from the book
a long way home by still in brine early
moonlight screenplay by Bailey Jenkins
and story by to our other machine based
women play in England black boys cook
foods by Tyrell Alvin McCraney and the
Oscar goes to
Barry Jenkins and Carol Alvin McCraney
from your life
[Music]
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Tarell Alvin McCraney and the first win
for Barry Jenkins who's also nominated
this year for the resting human life
[Applause]
thank you to the Academy Thank You 824
Thank You Plan B thank you with daily
romance Keys thank you our amazing
phenomenal cast thank you my mom my
sister everybody in Miami I also want to
thank my reps the three amigos Jay Baker
at CAA jewel Ross and Jamie Feldman and
I have to thank two women in particular
my publicist Paula woods and has a
secret satay 24 thank you for taking
care of me you know I told my students
that I teach sometimes be in love with
the process not the result but I would
really want this result cause the
bajillion people are watching and all
you people out there who feel like
there's no mirror for you that your life
is not reflected the Academy has your
back the ACLU has your back we have your
back and for the next four years we will
not leave you alone we will not forget
you I just want to echo everything you
just said in all those things but I also
want to say thank God for my mother who
proved to me through her struggles and
the struggles that Naomi Harris
portrayed for all of you that we can
really be here and be somebody two boys
from Liberty City up here on this stage
representing 305 this goes out to all
those black and brown boys and girls and
non gender conforming who don't see
themselves we're trying to show you you
and us so thank you thank you this is
for you
[Applause]